Das war's für heute und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder, bis dahin, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss.
Das war's für heute und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder, tschüss, tschüss.
Das war's für heute und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder.
Moin Leute, heute Nacht muss ich mega Mokka essen.
Aber richtig, ich hab gedacht, was ist denn da los?
Jetzt kurz die Musik leiser machen oder irgendwas anderes anmachen.
Gleich deutlich entspannter.
Wie gesagt, heute Nacht muss ich mega Mokka essen und zwar, ich habe ja gestern erzählt,
ich habe immer nachts ein bisschen Livestream auf dem Handy laufen und irgendwann krackt es auch mal ab.
Ich hab die ganze Zeit im Hintergrund heute Nacht, ich war so leicht am Schlafen und im Hintergrund habe ich gehört,
dass es irgendwie macht so, und ich dachte, das ist irgendwas aus dem Livestream, ja, weil ich hab ja immer ein bisschen Livestream laufen im Hintergrund, wenn ich am Pennen bin auf dem Handy.
So und irgendwann bin ich dann aufgewacht, hab mir gedacht, was ist das für ein komisches Geräusch, das wiederholt sich.
Und dann hab ich festgestellt, der Livestream ist aus, Handy war aus.
Das heißt, irgendwo aus meinem Zimmer kamen Geräusche, also irgendwo aus meinem Schlafzimmer kamen Geräusche, die ich noch nie vorher gehört hab und ich absolut nicht zuordnen konnte.
Ich hab an jedem Handy gelauscht, ihr kennt das vielleicht, da liegst du dann im Bett und denkst dir, ok, wo kommt das her?
Links, rechts, eher von links? Na ok, habe ich am ersten Smartphone Ohr dran gehalten, von da kam es nicht.
Zwei Smartphone des Ohr dran gehalten, kam es auch nicht. An das Tablet des Ohr dran gehalten, da kam es auch nicht her.
Was ist das? Ist das irgendein Viech in der Klimaanlage oder was ist das?
Nee, es war auch nicht die Katze, also das hört sich anders an.
Außerdem rührt die sich dann, wenn sie sehen, dass ich mich bewege.
Aber zumindest, keine Ahnung, wo kommt das her?
Da hab ich mich ins Bett gesetzt, also noch Licht aus alles, hab mit dem Bett gesetzt, hab mir den Kopf gedreht, von links, von rechts, von nicht, konnte es nicht genau an.
Es war auch unterschiedlich laut, nicht immer, immer, immer, immer gleich laut, nicht immer, hat sich nicht gleich angehört, aber so ganz komisch.
Ich hab erst gedacht, ok, ich hab irgendein Viech in der Klimaanlage, irgendwas, was in die Klimaanlage reingekommen ist von außen, wie auch immer.
Und da jetzt drin rum abkratzen ist oder so, keine Ahnung.
Oder aber, und das ist ja, wo ich ein bisschen, warte mal, hab ich noch ein Monka Giga Emote oder so?
Nee, keine Ahnung. Wo ich ja eher so ein bisschen mehr Bedenken hab, ist, dass ich irgendwelche fetten Viecher bei mir im Zimmer hab,
so sei es jetzt irgendwelche zwei Meter großen Spinnen oder so, die komische Geräusche nachts machen.
Habt ihr schon mal eine Spinne laufen hören?
Ey, es ist voll abartig, ja. Ihr habt mal so ein riesen Viech im Bad in der alten Wohnung.
Ja, zumindest, so Dinger will ich nicht, das muss nicht sein.
Da hab ich da ein bisschen Panik davor gehabt, Alter, was ist das?
So, zumindest, lange Rede, kurzer Sinn, ich mach's Licht an und guck mal ein bisschen rum.
Und wisst ihr, was es war im Endeffekt?
Es war die Flasche mit Sprudelwasser, die nicht richtig zu war.
Aber es hat sich ganz merkwürdig, ihr kennt das Geräusch, was Sprudelwasser macht, wenn der Deckel nicht richtig zu ist.
Das macht halt so, so vor sich hin und dann immer mit Pause.
Das Geräusch, das hab ich noch nie wirklich so wahrgenommen.
Ich hab übelst Panik gekriegt, da hab ich gedacht, was ist denn jetzt hier?
Und da hab ich gedacht, das ist die Sprudelflasche, äh, die Sprudelwasserflasche.
Schweres Wort, Alter, ja.
Ja, ich riech gemonker Est heute Nacht.
Danach hab ich erinnerlich ein bisschen Kek weht, als ich gesehen hab, dass es die Sprudelflasche ist.
Easy.
Die Sodastreamflasche, ja.
Genau, so eine haben wir auch.
Das Ding ist übrigens richtig, damals hieß es noch Soda Club.
Mittlerweile heißt es Sodastream.
Aber so einen Teil hab ich schon seit 20 Jahren oder so.
Ewig, also ich trage schon lange keine Kisten mit Wasser mehr hoch, weil ich Plastikflaschen hab.
Das ist richtig nice.
Das Einzige, was man manchmal holen muss, ist so eine Pressluftsprudel, was auch immer, das ist Flasche.
Aber es ist richtig nice.
Äh, Medic sagt, ihr müsst mal eine 5cm-Spinne unter die Tastatur laufen.
Ich hab's noch aus dem Augenwinkel gesehen.
Alter, monkaS.
Ähm, das Schlimme ist, also es gibt zwei Sachen.
Und das sind eigentlich auch so die einzigen Sachen, wo ich echt Schiss vor hab.
Also du kannst mich weder mit Schlangen, noch mit Mäusen, noch mit irgendwas anderes schocken, ja.
Auch mit ekligem Krams, ja.
Sei es irgendwie hingekotzt, hingeschissen, was auch immer.
Juckt mich alles nicht, ist mir alles egal.
Es gibt zwei Sachen, aber zwei komplett unterschiedliche paar Sachen, vor denen ich Schiss hab.
Das Erste ist, tiefes Wasser.
Fragt mich nicht warum, keine Ahnung.
Aber ich glaub, das haben viele.
Aber lustigerweise, nur wenn ich schwimme.
Wenn ich tauche, ist okay.
Das ist merkwürdig.
Also wenn ich schwimme, sei es in irgendeinem See oder so.
Schwimme, wenn ich nicht genau weiß, wie tief es drunter ist.
Geht schon teilweise im Sprungbecken vom Schwimmbad los.
Wenn ich weiß, AS350 oder so tief.
Und vor allem, wenn du dann oben drauf stehst, dann ist es dann noch mal so hoch von oben, wenn du guckst.
Da hab ich übel Schiss vor.
Wobei, lustigerweise, wenn ich dann reingehe.
Manchmal, es gibt ja Sprungbecken mit 10 Meter, da ist es dann auch 3,50 Meter tief, dass die Leute nicht aufklatschen.
Und wenn ich dann einfach so ins Wasser gehe und da runtertauche, überhaupt kein Problem.
Juckt mich nicht, finde ich sogar interessant.
Gerade im Dings, wie heißt das Schwimmbad in Frankfurt?
Ob es das überhaupt noch gibt?
War das Taunus? Taunustherme? Taunustherme? Taunustherme?
Ne, äh, Moment, wie heißt das?
Alter, das mach ich nicht.
Wie heißt dann das eine Schwimmbad in Frankfurt mit der großen, große Rutsche?
Was sind denn die Taunustherme?
Rebstockbad mein ich, genau. Rebstockbad in Frankfurt.
Nein, ich bin nicht so profimäßig wie der Krieger.
Zumindest das Schwimmbad, da bin ich früher übelst gern hin mit meinem Vater gegangen, weil die haben so eine Wellenstelle.
Also da hinten ist so ein Ding, was Wellen macht.
Da kannst du dich dann da rumwellen lassen.
Zumindest die haben einen Becken, wo man reinsprungbrett, die haben, ich weiß nicht ob es davon Bilder gibt.
Genau, so.
Das ist das Becken, das geht bis zu 10 Meter, geht bis zu 10 Meter oder 7 Meter, doch ich glaube 10 Meter.
Zumindest geht es relativ hoch hier zum Unterspringen.
Und hier unten haben die ein Fenster drin.
Kennst du Wellenbad in China?
Ja, das kenne ich.
Das kenne ich, wo die Leute auf einen Haufen von der Welle geschmissen werden.
Hier unten, also da hatte ich übelst Schiss reinzugehen in das Wasser, weil es so tief ist.
Also das hat, Runterspringen 10 Meter hat mich auch nicht geschockt.
Ich hatte damals sogar den goldenen Dings-Freischwimmer oder wie das Ding hieß.
Diese Abzeichen, die man immer so an die Badehose gepappt hat und sich richtig geil vorkam.
Zumindest hier unten haben die ein Fenster drin, in diesem Sprungbecken.
Und da bin ich dann immer runtergetaucht und habe durchgeguckt und irgendwann habe ich festgestellt, hinter diesem Fenster ist halt so ein Maintenance-Ding.
So ein Maintenance-Tunnel, wo manchmal Leute durchlaufen.
Dann bin ich dann irgendwie gefühlt den halben Tag da runtergetaucht, nur um den Leuten zu winken, wenn da mal einer durch den Tunnel geläuft.
Kommst du aus Frankfurt? Ja.
Also das Rebstockbad, da bin ich früher echt gerne hingegangen.
Also das ist super Bad, ich weiß gar nicht, ob es das überhaupt noch gibt in Frankfurt, ob das überhaupt noch offen ist.
Keine Ahnung, ob es das noch gibt.
Keine Ahnung mehr, anscheinend doch, doch gibt es noch.
Aber auch für Familien ist das ein super Ausflug.
Du hast hier einmal was recht Seichtes, du hast dieses Wellenmaschinen-Ding, du hast Sprungbretter, du kannst ins Freie raus und du hast eine richtig geile Rutsche.
Die geht irgendwie, warte mir nicht, 300 Meter oder so.
Die geht von hier oben hier rein, raus ins Freie und runter.
Also die Rutsche ist echt nice.
Guck mal hier, die Rutsche ist echt nice.
Also da geht einiges mit der Rutsche her.
Die haben das mittlerweile zugemacht.
Also früher war in den Kurven auf jeden Fall noch oben offen.
Früher war in den Kurven oder außen definitiv noch oben offen.
Wahrscheinlich wurden die Leute getriggert, weil sie sonst aus dem Dach fallen könnten.
Okay, Rebstock, Bad, Frankfurt, ja das gucken wir uns jetzt mal an.
Übrigens, das sind die Noobs, also Rutschen auf dem Rücken und Rutschen auf dem Bobbes ist Lowskill.
Wer richtig schnell Wasserrutschen rutschen will, der nimmt Anlauf und springt rein und rutscht auf den Knien runter.
Setz keinen mit, das geht übelst ab.
Das flutscht richtig.
So richtig mit Anlauf, ich kenne das auch schon als irgendwelche FIFA Games.
Wo die dann Fußballjubel machen, so rennen und springen und so mit auf den Knien über den Rasen rutschen.
So musst du in die Rutsche springen, dann geht es richtig ab.
Okay, Nackter Bobbes geht auch, allerdings Nackter Bobbes im öffentlichen Schwimmbad ist ein bisschen schwierig.
Wie groß soll die Rutsche sein?
Wieso? Kein Problem, ich rede jetzt auch nicht davon, dass der Ausgewachsene zwei Meter Mann reingeht.
Ich bin da immer voll reingesprungen und auf den Knien runtergerutscht, das geht übelst ab.
Dann habe ich unten keinen Knien mehr, Quatsch, überhaupt kein Problem.
Das rutscht ja, das ist eine Rutsche.
So, also gucken wir uns mal an.
Die war auch blau früher, die war doch nicht aus Metall, die war doch ziemlich sicher, war die blau und aus Plastik früher.
E-Modes, bald.
Ja, da bist du schon eine Weile unterwegs hier, ne?
Also die Rutsche geht, die Rutsche geht wirklich schon, die geht ne ganze Weile.
Äh, Moment, Hyper S.
Und der ist auch recht schnell unterwegs, doch früher war das definitiv offen.
Früher war es in den Kurven offen oben, die Rutsche.
Und es war nur an den Kurven an der Seite so ein bisschen was, dass die Leute nicht rausgefallen sind.
Wahrscheinlich hatten die Leute Panik, dass sie rausfallen aus der Rutsche.
Aber heute hatte jeder vor jedem alles irgendwie Panik.
Geht sogar so weit, gibt es da noch was von früher?
Ebstockbad, Rutsche, gibt es da noch von früher Aufnahmen?
Weil so sah es definitiv nicht aus früher.
In der Rutsche geht...
1KS, Alter.
Was geht mit denen ab?
Früher war die blau und teilweise offen.
Deswegen sag ich, du musst auf die Knie runterrutschen.
Dann geht es ab.
Ne, gibt es anscheinend keine Bilder mit früher.
Aber da bin ich früher extrem gerne hin.
Moin.
Chronics, der Knerbeer ist auch am Start.
JZ, der Knallbusch.
Da sind ja richtig viele Leute schon da hier.
Ja, zumindest eine extrem leiste Geschichte.
Ja, und das hat mich heute Nacht halt geschockt.
Ich weiß jetzt auch, wie bin ich jetzt eigentlich auf diese komische...
Ach ja, genau.
Und hier noch was zum Thema Rutsche.
Als ich ja gesagt hab, früher war das hier nicht überdacht.
Außen und auch nur in den Kurven, im Deckel drüber.
Ich hab da das Gefühl, dass sie mittlerweile Schiss haben, dass die Leute rausfallen.
Was mir aufgefallen ist, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, woran es liegt.
Ob es aus irgendwelchen Haftungsgründen ist oder sonst wo.
Dass ganz viele Sachen, die früher anders gebaut haben.
Zum Beispiel war es so, ich bin letztens wieder mal an der Schule vorbeigelaufen.
Wo ich halt in die Schule gegangen bin.
Also an beiden vorbeigelaufen.
Sogar die Grundschule war abgesperrt.
Früher war die Grundschule immer komplett auf, weil da ist so ein Übungsplatz gewesen,
wo man Fahrradfahren und mit Verkehrsschildern üben konnte auf dem Schulgelände.
Alles abgeschlossen und sogar extra Schild dran, dass du nicht betreten darfst.
Und die andere Schule, wo ich danach hingegangen bin,
konntest du früher auch ohne Probleme von vorne nach hinten durchlaufen.
Hast du halt in der Regel nur gemacht, wenn halt keine Pause war.
Weil sonst ein bisschen merkwürdig, wenn du einfach nicht in die Schule gehst, da random drüberläufst.
Aber das war komplett offen. Heute komplett eingezäunt, komplett Zauntrum.
Vor was haben die eigentlich Schiss?
Was haben die da Schiss, dass die Leute zu dumm sind und sich verlaufen auf dem Hof,
wenn da kein Zauntrum herum ist oder wie?
Ich glaub ja eher, dass das daran liegt, dass mittlerweile die Leute durch jeden Scheiß triggert sind.
So nach dem Motto, oh nein, da könnte ja was passieren, wenn da kein Zauntrum herum ist.
Was soll da passieren? Ich frag mich eh, wie das funktioniert hat.
Man muss sich mal vorstellen, als ich in die Schule gegangen bin,
sind die meisten Leute entweder, da gab es drei Sachen.
Es gab die, die mit dem Bus gekommen sind, die waren ein bisschen weiter weg,
welche, die mit dem Fahrrad gefahren sind und die, die gelaufen sind.
Ich hab so ein Zwischenling zwischen Fahrradfahren und Laufen gemacht.
Für Bus war ich zu nah dran.
Mittlerweile ist es so, ich bin letztens an der Schule vorbeigelaufen,
die haben gegenüber und rechts quasi Parkplätze
und hinten noch ein, zwei dahinten noch mal eine riesen Abhol-Entlade-Zone,
wo ich mir denke, okay, anscheinend holen heute 90% der Eltern Kinder in die Schule ab
und bringen sie wieder. Wie geht das überhaupt, wenn man arbeiten geht?
Es hätte mich früher überhaupt, ja doch, mein Opa hätte mich früher abholen können vielleicht.
Aber ist, ist das so, ist das so schlimm die Welt heutzutage,
dass man sein Kindern nicht mehr zutrauen kann,
für Viertelstunde von der Schule heim zu laufen und zurück?
Ich mein, es ist ja nicht so, als wäre jetzt die Welt wahnsinnig gefährlicher geworden
als vor 20 Jahren.
Ach, ich weiß auch nicht. Merkwürdig.
Das ist vielleicht, das ist vielleicht einfach eine andere Zeit, ja.
Gut, heute hast du eine Leute mit der Axt in der, in der, im, im, im RB,
der mit der, der mit der Axt auf die Leute zurent, ja.
Das hatst du vielleicht, früher war das nicht so präsent, dass sowas passiert ist.
Es ist bestimmt auch passiert, aber man hat es nicht so oft und nicht so, nicht so groß.
Aber, also ich glaube nicht, dass es so großartig, großartig gefährlicher ist,
heute eine Viertelstunde von der Schule heim zu laufen als vor 20 Jahren.
Ich weiß auch nicht, also es ist merkwürdig.
Und irgendwie sind die Leute bei, bei vielem heute direkt getriggert,
dass das ultra gefährlich ist und dir bei allem irgendwas passieren kann.
Ich frag mich, ich frag mich ganz ernst, es war ja, das war ja bei mir schon so,
dass bei uns, wir waren ja schon relativ behütet, muss man sagen.
Ja, also bei uns haben ja auch immer die Leute aufgepasst.
Sei es die Eltern, sei es Opa, Oma, sonst wie, dass das alles in Ordnung gewesen ist.
Ich frag mich ganz ernsthaft, wie hat das die Generation von, von Opa und Oma überhaupt
jetzt mal den zweiten Weltkrieg außen vor, ja, wenn die ein bisschen später...
Wie haben die das überlebt alle?
Da war ja nichts.
Ist ja...
Da gab es dann teilweise Familien mit sechs Kindern und die mussten sich die ganze
Nacht irgendwie mit sich selbst beschäftigen.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie die das überlebt haben.
Wie soll das überhaupt gehen?
Ohne, ohne Internet.
Die mussten rausgehen.
Kann man sich das vorstellen?
Ich kann mir das auch nicht mal vorstellen.
Die mussten rausgehen und da irgendwas machen.
Ins Freie.
Das ist ja, es ist ja echt Massive Pains Champ.
So an die Sonne und sowas.
Nee.
Also war ich im Ernst.
Wer will denn, wer will denn sowas?
Ohne Internet und alles, ja.
Mit Freunden auf dem Spielplatz.
Ja, sowas kommt ja heute nicht mehr vor.
Heute ist eher mit Freunden Fortnite angesagt.
Und damals, damals waren wir noch die, die, die, äh, so die Außen, äh, die Außenseite
des YouTube Channel.
Wie soll man das nennen?
Ja doch.
Damals waren wir noch eher die Außenseite, weil man sie hingesetzt hat mit fünf Leuten
und CS gespielt hat, anstatt irgendwelche coolen Aktionen zu machen.
Na ja.
Was ist denn das?
Das ist bestimmt mega langweilig, oder?
Leute, Fortnite-Tänze tanzen.
Ich hab das ja nicht für möglich gehalten, dass die Leute wirklich so degeneriert im
Kopf sind, was Fortnite-Tänze angeht.
Aber nachdem ich vor einem Jahr oder so mal am Südbahnhof, keine Ahnung, ne Gruppe, was
war das, 10-Jähriger oder so gesehen hab, die vor die S-Bahn oder vor den Bus, nee,
vor die, vor die, vor die, vor die Straßenbahn, schwachsinn, was?
Vor die Straßenbahn gehüpft sind.
Die Straßenbahn hält am Südbahnhof.
Und da sind die vor die Straßenbahn gehüpft und haben den Loser-Dance gemacht, auf der,
auf der Kleise.
Und ich dachte ja wirklich, die Leute sind nicht so degeneriert, aber doch.
Sitze sie.
Ein, One-Head, da ist der, da ist hier, da ist drei Kopf nicht mehr genug.
Das muss doch eins, erkennt noch eins tiefer.
Direkt umgefahren, ja, natürlich passen die auf.
Okay, was erklärt er uns Netzwerk-Kabel?
Okay, nee, das Video ist langweilig.
Oh nee.
Das ist Theorie-Crafting, 11 Minuten.
Nee, nee, nee, das gucken wir uns jetzt an.
So, was gucken wir uns jetzt an?
Also, Police, oh, just Kokona-Things.
Da steht einfach, was ist das, M16 oder so oder M4?
Da hängt einfach mal, das ist halt Hell-Yeah-Brother.
Okay.
Moment, Moment, aber, also das ausrangierte
das ausrangierte polizeifahrzeug was er da hat
das wurde nicht mit waffe geliefert oder
also die waffe hat er schon selbst reingemacht ich weil ich trau den ich trau den alles zu so sowohl denen als auch den
trau ich alles zu in der richtung
wobei den den denen eher den eher also den würde ich auch also den amis würde ich ohne probleme zutrauen dass
ähm sie ein polizeiauto ausmustern inklusive m4 das wird mich nicht wundern
Moment es gibt kein kokona emote mehr
Warum warum geht es kokona emote im chat bei mir nicht
haben die kokona entfernt
Echt bei mir geht kokona nicht hat sich vielleicht mein ffz irgendwie verabschiedet
Mein ffz hat sich verabschiedet
Ich muss mal meinen chat reloaden ich glaube das spakt rum
Moment
Kokona, ah jetzt funktioniert es wieder ok
So
Sonderlich stabil sieht das ganze auch nicht aus ne
Daniel dankeschön, exzellent
Ohnack S
Wat? Moment
Einfach wackeln mit dem schlüssel ernsthaft jetzt
Das ging aber schnell das ging aber schnell
Ja gut wenn wenn der leute erschießen muss dann muss das zackig gehen
Ok, exzellent, exzellent schloss
Jetzt schloss
Schloss
Unschloss
Ich bin wirklich frustriert wenn ich so Produkte sehe
Sie sind teuerlich schloss mit einem verdammt seriösen Ziel
Es ist einfach unbeschädigend in meiner Meinung dass sie in ein paar Momente mit einem 0-Skill-Pack
Das hätte ich nicht gedacht
Heftig, das hätte ich nicht gedacht dass es so einfach geht
Ich mein du musst erstmal drankommen ja ich mein das ding ist wahrscheinlich im wo ist es wo haben die das
Im kokona police car im im im koffer im kofferraum oder haben die das irgendwo unter besitz oder wo ist das
Wahrscheinlich im kofferraum ist ja bisschen wenig platz oder an den türen oder so ich trau den alles zu keine ahnung
Aber heftig so was haben wir sonst noch zu tun
Essentials tool you will need electronic projects
Future of the ablore
How safe is the so
What
Ich hoffe das video ist nicht blutig
Jetzt gucken wir uns jetzt an
Bisschen leise
So ganz einfach muss man einfach aufpassen
Was ist überhaupt ein Sawstop also ich kann mir anhand des namens ja was zusammenreimen es ist was was die Säge stoppt
Auf die Idee sind wir wahrscheinlich alle schon gekommen
Aber was es genau ist ich hab keine ahnung
Er erkennt den finger und stoppt die säge soll es denn den finger erkennen
Ja vor allem ok wie man den finger erkennt das könnte ich mir noch vorstellen dass das irgendwie gut funktioniert aber
Wie will man das schnell stoppen
Ich mein das ding ist da guck mal das so ein säge platt
Keine ahnung mit was ich das drehe zehntausend umdrehungen die die minute ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht
Das müsstest du ja dann quasi so extrem schnell stoppen
Dass wahrscheinlich das siegenplatz zerbricht oder so
Also ich kann mir das nicht vorstellen
2020 exzellent also wenn schon will ich den Sawstop mit USB haben und HDMI 4k
Der will nicht seine Sägespäne in der Werkstatt rumfliegen haben, das kann ich gar nicht verstehen.
Wenn er echt Vertrauen in den Sawstop hätte, würde das mit seinem Finger machen.
Das ist die beste und geilste Säge mit dem besten und geilsten Sawstop.
Alles klar, ist ja auch klar, was soll denn sonst da?
Außer das beste.
Ist das eine Wurst?
Es geht ja mega schnell, vor allem das Ding ist richtig clever, das stoppt so wie es sich anhört und geht gleichzeitig runter.
Also weißt du, das ist eigentlich schon eher so hier. Aber mindestens so.
Guck mal, das geht richtig gut, guck mal hier.
Okay, hier hat es ein bisschen reingekratzt, das ist jetzt nicht so das Problem am Finger, das blutet ein bisschen, aber okay.
Das muss ja irgendwie blocken. Alter, habt ihr gesehen, wie schnell das stoppt? Komm mal hier, zack, das sind ja Millisekunden und es ist direkt weg.
Krass, das hätte ich nicht gedacht, dass es so schnell geht.
Von der Erkennung am Finger dran, ich habe keine Ahnung, wie das funktioniert, hoffentlich erklärt das uns.
Ist ja nice.
Ah, okay, also sprich, die leiten irgendwie drei Volt Spannung durch die Säge platt und wenn das irgendwie abfällt, weil du mit dem Finger dran kommst, löst instant die Bremse aus.
Und die Bremse ist auch keine Bremse im eigentlichen Sinn, sondern es ist einfach ein Stück Metall, was direkt blockiert.
Deswegen ist wahrscheinlich das Säge platt danach auch im Arsch.
Guck mal hier, was da für Zeug rumfliegt, wenn das rein basht.
Das Säge platt ist voll im Arsch wahrscheinlich danach, aber ich meine ganz ehrlich, besser der Finger noch dran als das Säge platt im Arsch und Finger noch dran als Finger ab und Säge platt gut.
Ja, guck mal hier, das ist auf jeden Fall RIP danach.
Guck mal, seht ihr wie sich das Säge platt zerlegt? Also das Säge platt zerlegt sich halb und zerlegt dabei noch die Bremse halb. Guck mal.
Das war's für heute.
Wir könnten es auch mit einem Baguette ausprobieren, aber Baguette leitet nicht so gut denke ich mal.
Krass, guck mal wie schnell das geht.
Okay, wie dick ist so eine Wurst, so Daumendick ungefähr oder? So ungefähr Daumendick würde ich sagen ist die Wurst.
Das heißt, das hätte je nachdem, das hätte auf jeden Fall so knapp bis, also von der Seite, das hätte schon so weit reingeschnitten bis zum Daumennagel ungefähr.
Die schnellste Variante, ja.
Natürlich, natürlich, natürlich sägt keiner so schnell, ja.
Ich mein so schnell sägt ja keiner. Du schiebst das ja langsam ran. Dann hast du wirklich nur einen Kratzer.
Guck dir das an, das ist ziemlich verrückt. Mit all der Geschwindigkeit und Inertie, und du weißt, ich bin durchgezogen in die Wurst.
Es hat nur das Hotdog von einem Echsein von einem Inch geschnitten.
Gegen meinen Daumen, das würde nicht so nahe sein, wie ein Bogen. Mit einem Echsein von einem Inch kannst du kaum in die Flasche kommen.
Du wirst ein paar Stiche haben, aber du wirst sicherlich wieder an der Arbeit sein, sobald du deine Stiche rauskommst. Und es würde wirklich keinen langweiligen Schaden machen.
Ich war super beeindruckt von dem, denn ich habe das alles, was ich hatte. Und ich denke, das zeigt, dass du für irgendeinen Grund in deinem Geschäft springst.
Okay, was ist ein Achtlinch?
Inch Millimeter.
Drei Millimeter.
Drei Millimeter ist wirklich nicht so viel.
Das ist so ganz knapp am Daumennagel so ungefähr. So oft von der Tiefe her.
Du warst an und fielst direkt in dein Blut. Du wirst mit nur einem kleinen Schnitt weg. Oder ich denke, was es wirklich zeigt, ist, wenn du einen großen Kickback hattest.
Also wenn du schon vor deinem Blut einen großen Kickback hattest, und es einfach mit vollem Geschwindigkeit durch deine Hand rief.
Du wirst einen kleinen Knick bekommen, aber deine Finger werden noch einen anderen Tag kämpfen. Und das ist ziemlich unglaublich.
Aber ich denke, dass ich mich wirklich beeindruckt von dem Schuss, den wir gemacht haben, war die Dato-Aktivation.
Also während ein 10-Inch-Blatt 2lb wiegt, kann ein Dato-Stack 5-8lb wiegen.
Das sind so 2,8-4x so viele Gs. Ich bin kein Physiker, aber ihr könnt das in den Kommentaren beschreiben.
Wenn man sich die Dato-Aktivation anschaut, funktioniert es auch so.
Die Breitkartridge ist allerdings größer.
Einerseits, weil sie mehr Distanz binden muss, denn es ist ein kleinerer Diameter-Blatt.
Also muss es noch größer sein.
Aber es ist auch größer, weil es so viel mehr Kraft braucht.
Diese Kraft war so intensiv, dass wir etwas auf die Kamera gefangen haben, dass ich gar nicht weiß, ob du glauben wirst.
Das Ding ist danach im Arsch, aber es ist ja egal. Dafür ist der Finger noch dran.
Das Ding ist danach im Arsch, aber es ist ja egal.
Was ist in Europa illegal?
Das zweite Sägeblatt, okay.
Mehrere Blätter nebenan, das ist illegal, was für was wir alles regeln haben.
Das ist ja nice.
Also es heißt, wenn ich mir irgendwann mal eine Säge kaufen sollte, kaufe ich was mit Sawstop.
Allerdings kaufe ich mir keine Säge, weil ich wüsste nicht, was ich damit machen soll.
Koste aber den Haufen.
Besser Finger dran als Finger ab, ne?
Ich kaufe mir wahrscheinlich eh keine Säge, ich habe da absolut keinen Anwendungszweck für gerade.
Was haben wir sonst noch zu bieten?
Essential Tools, Diablo Future, Emo-Geschichte, do-it-yourself-home-automation-for-beginner.
Automate your garage door.
Oh, das ist Big Brain-Time.
Ich meine, mein garage door muss ich eh nicht automatisieren, weil mein garage door ist im Prinzip einfach nur eine Müllhalde.
Nee, oder wenigstens ein Lager, die Garage.
Da steht ja das Auto nicht drin.
Remember Killstreak in Black Ops 1?
Oh komm, wir gucken mal eine Runde.
Ich will gucken mal eine Runde Black Ops 1.
Ich habe jetzt echt Bock, wieder eine Runde Black Ops 1 zu gucken.
The Soundtrack ja
Drop a like if you guys do enjoy the video and if you want to see more black ops 1 content, let me know down in the comments below
Also, I want to know what was your favorite killstreak of all?
Da war schon viel crap dabei, ne?
Sentry gun zum Beispiel nie gespielt, sem turret nie gespielt, mortar team auch relativ, valkyrie rockets haben gesagt
Rolling thunder war jetzt auch nicht so geil
I waited about 30 minutes to finally find one team deathmatch. I don't know if the servers are messed up or if no one's playing this game, but
Regardless wahrscheinlich spielst kaum einer
So basically i'm just gonna go through all the killstreaks here in black ops 1
Starting from some of the simpler ones moving on to more of the heavier ones galil silenced best
Just for a nostalgia sake I just cannot believe it took me that long to find a game, you know the frickin main menu says one point seven million people online
Ja das stimmt ja eh nicht
Spielst du noch das neue modern warfare aktiv? Ich spiele ab und zu mal warzone ja
Aber ansonsten gar nicht
Kann sie kann sich aber jetzt wo ist das rcxd k moment moment kann sich doch irgendjemand an das video erinnern
mameticht
Yup kommt das doch jemand mit dem famian am start
Aufgenommen mit der schlechtesten playstation kamera aller zeit
Ich habe die Rollos hingestellt, weil wir hatten gestern schon mal ein Video aufgenommen.
Wo ist das RC Car? Wo ist das RC Car?
Ja, Black Ops RC Car.
Der sieht ja aus wie 12. Der Fabian sah halt ewig aus wie 17, 18. Mittlerweile sieht er auch ein bisschen älter aus.
Nein, mach das nicht. Das ist übelst dumm. Meine Katzen haben davor Angst.
Die Leute haben ja geschwört, sie haben mich in den Spiegeln gesehen.
Excellent Driving Skills. Habt ihr noch Kontakt? Ja klar. Wir kennen uns ja auch schon vor YouTube Zeug.
Oh, komm schon.
Ich versuche mich zu erinnern, aber ich bin mir nicht 100% sicher. Wie viele Assisten werde ich bekommen?
Aber ich erinnere mich, dass viele Leute mit Flakjacket begonnen haben. Und ich bin mir sicher, dass es wegen all den RCXDs war.
Ich bin fast positiv, dass die Flakjacket die RCXD von Pointblank Range enthalten könnte.
Sam Turret ist bereit für die Delivery.
Sam Turret war in ein paar Spielen. Ich weiß nicht, welche Spiele Sam Turret war.
Aber es war ein Stinger von Model Warfare 2.
Wenn ihr den Sam Turret nie genutzt habt, dann schießt ihr alle Killsstreaks, die in den Himmel gehen.
Übelste Killsstreak. Hat nie jemand mitgenommen.
Wenn man das nicht schafft, ragesquittet man einfach aus dem Game.
Der war gut. Der war gut.
Der Napalmstrike war nice.
Vor allem gab es immer genug Noobs, die reingelaufen sind in das Napalm noch nachträglich.
Vom Multiplayer her ist Modern Warfare das mit Abstand schlecht. Der Multiplayer ist so für'n Arsch und Warzone hat dem Game krass den Arsch gerettet.
Was? Der hat einen Flak-Jacket an.
MP ist nur zum Waffeleffeln.
Vor allem den Sam Turret musste man ja auch noch aus einer Kiste holen. Das war so ein richtiger Crap-Killstreak.
Man konnte die aber rerollen. Ganz am Anfang war das OP. Man konnte den Sam Turret rerollen zu einem Chopper-Gunner.
Aber ansonsten hast du das nicht mitgenommen.
Weggesprayen, Prey. Moin von der Arbeit. Moin Krischpe. Warum musst du arbeiten sonntags?
Auch war auch Poggers Waffe. Obwohl ich sagen muss, Farmers war ja mehr oder weniger das gleiche.
Kommando, Galil Silenced und Farmers beste.
Valkyrie Rockets waren so mies schlecht.
Arbeiten durch. Wir haben sehr viel Arbeit. Krass. Ist überhaupt erlaubt?
Die Valkyrie Rockets waren auch Crap. Das Ding ging.
Warum hat man noch mal Weise nicht mehr? Das einzig gute an dem Killstreak war, dass er durch Dächer ging.
Es war aber, wenn du so willst, OP, dass du mit dem Napalm-Strike mehr oder weniger das gleiche hingekriegt hast.
Vor allem, dass die aus der Kiste kommen ist Kacke. Hätte man die direkt auslösen können, wäre besser gewesen.
Erst mal hoch und dann muss man runterfliegen. Das ist selten.
Das stimmt. Die waren Müll.
Ich denke, es würden noch genug Leute klassische Call of Duty-Multiplayer spielen.
Aktuell ist Battle Royale angesagt, aber man darf ja nicht vom Jetzt-Stand ausgehen.
Battle Royale ist auch was, was jetzt 4 Jahre alt ist und wenn es was Neues gibt, sind die Leute bereit, was Neues zu spielen.
Es muss halt gut sein. Battle Royale wird überleben, sieht man ja auch an den ganzen MOBAs.
Welcher Hype total schnell wieder vorbei war, war diese Auto-Battler-Geschichte.
Ein bisschen ist noch da, die das gucken, aber der Hype ist ganz schnell wieder weg gewesen. Es gab viele Gaming-Hypes, wo auch ein Portion davon überlebt hat, aber es spricht überhaupt nichts dagegen, dass wenn ein neues gutes Battlefield kommt oder ein neues gutes Call of Duty mit ordentlich Multiplayer, dass das auch viele Leute spielen werden.
Ach, das war der Mörder und die Mörser. Zombie-Games, Survival-Geschichten, Crafting-Sachen. Alles hat irgendwie ein bisschen überlebt, aber nicht in der Masse.
Nach 200 Stunden hat es ein... Nö, finde ich nicht. Gute Spiele kannst du viel länger spielen, also welche mit einem ordentlichen Endgame. Guckt euch mal Leute an, wie lange haben Leute CS gespielt? Tausende Stunden. 200 Stunden ist ja nichts.
200 Stunden für ein Single-Player-Spiel, für irgendwie so eine Art... Sag mal so, wenn du 200 Stunden hast jetzt in Borderlands oder so. Okay, dann ist was anderes. Stellsort 10 Monate, Dankeschön. Exzellent.
Also ich glaube ja, dass das neue Call of Duty gar kein Battle Royale beinhalten wird. Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass die Warzone weiter betreiben parallel und das nächste Call of Duty Multiplayer Only wird.
Also mit Kampagne diesmal. Ich glaube nicht, dass die Multiplayer Only, aber ohne Battle Royale. Ich fände es komisch, wenn die nach dem riesen Erfolg und den dauerhaft anhaltenden hohen Spielzahlen von Warzone das rausnehmen.
Vielleicht kriegt sie einen Refresh mit Cold War. Vielleicht kriegt sie mit Cold War eine neue Map oder so. Mal gucken, bin mal gespannt wie sie das machen. Genau, das glaube ich auch. Das neue Call of Duty kriegt Kampagne-Zombie-Modus-Multiplayer. Und Warzone wird wahrscheinlich parallel weiter betrieben.
Vielleicht gibt es eine neue Map. Guck mal, Warzone hat so ein Potential auch mit dem neuen Call of Duty. Du kannst die Charaktere aus der Singleplayer reinbringen. Du kannst Waffen aus dem anderen Call of Duty bringen. Es gibt doch überhaupt keinen Grund, warum das an Modern Warfare gebunden sein sollte. Die lassen einfach den Modern Warfare-Part da sterben von. Das ist einfach nur noch Call of Duty Warzone.
Ja, 200 Stunden ist für ein Spiel schon lang. Aber halt nicht für die Ultra-Crime-Games. Aber insgesamt, so die Durchschnittsgröße ist schon lang. BÄÄÄM! Alter, ich habe glaube ich mit den Valkyrie-Rockets in der gesamten Spielzeit nicht so viele Kills gemacht, wie da in einem Game hier gerade.
Ich habe noch ein paar Black Ops 1 Gameplays, die ich schon ein halbes Jahr spiele.
Oh, das ist X11 oder so, ne?
G11, nicht X11.
Ja, das war richtig gut das Ding. Ich glaube, es gab ja zwei Burst-Waffen. Es gab die und die M16. Und ich glaube, die M16 hat ein bisschen weniger Damage gemacht als die G11.
Deswegen, ich glaube, das eine hat irgendwie 35 und das andere hat 40 gemacht. Also sprich, das eine war 3er Burst-Kill und das andere war irgendwie komisch.
Aber Silence, Galil, Commando und Pharma, das Beste. Erstmal schön ins Nuke Town auscampen. Exzellent.
Wisst ihr, was man hier an Nuke Town gut sieht? So scheiße ich Nuke Town fand. Ich weiß, dass Nuke Town viele Fans hatte. Ich meine, es wurde nicht umsonst dreimal remake. So scheiße ich Nuke Town fand. Man sieht, dass es irgendwie in Black Ops 1 auch noch halbwegs predictable war, wo was herkommt.
Stellt euch diese Map in Modern Warfare vor. In Modern Warfare spawnet jetzt hier auf dem Balkon einer und der killt alle drei. Total random. Und in Modern Warfare hättest du hier einen Head-Clitch-Spot, da einen Head-Clitch-Spot, da noch ein Fenster im Auto, hier einen Head-Clitch-Spot, hier einen Leiter oben drauf, hier einen Leiter oben drauf.
Hier hinten kannst du noch mal im Kreis gehen, da aufs Dach und hier oben aufs Dach kannst du auch Reinspawnen. So würden Nuke Town in Modern Warfare aussehen. Und da noch ein Fenster, da noch ein Fenster, wo du dich auflegen und Head-Clitchen kannst.
Doch, direkt über ihn. Ah, bester Killstreak in der gesamten History of dieser Spiele-Serie. Blackbird. Eigentlich viel zu OP, wenn man es genau nimmt, aber beste, beste.
Also gerade die Kombi mit Attack-Dogs war halt übelst geil.
Run out, du. Ah, der hat High-Kills-Licks gespielt. Acer 71, Chopper, Gunner und Hunde. Das ist für Nuke Town TDM viel zu viel. Die kriegst du gar nicht alle raus.
Die haben auch alle im Haus gecampt, wahrscheinlich.
Es hat übrigens eine Weile gedauert, bis ich gecheckt habe, dass man hier durchs Haus schießen kann. Zumindest teilweise. Oh, der wird gleich runtergegeiert.
Die wollten ihn direkt runtergeiern.
Ah, wie sie rein spawnen. Lul. Das war schon OP, ne? Gerade auf Nuke Town.
Aber Gunship hab ich sehr selten gespielt, weil das eigentlich ziemlich cool war mit Selbstkontrollieren und den Raketen.
Im Moment war halt das Problem, dass du zwei Kills mehr gebraucht hast. Alter, blinde Gegner.
Also in MW2 kann man sich darüber streiten, ob der Chopper besser war. Kommt ein bisschen auf die Map an.
In MW2 war alles OP, ja das stimmt schon. MW2 ist auch so extrem schnell gestorben.
Das hat er auch Raketen, das Ding, ne? Das Ding hat er auch Raketen, glaube ich. Ja, genau.
Stimmt, Sentry Gun. Das Ding hat auch kaum einen. Der Fabian hat das immer gespielt, wo ich mich bis heute frage, warum?
In Warzone ist auch viel OP. Ja, ich hab gehört, die neue 50-Kell-Sniper killt nicht One-Hit auf den Kopf.
Also die Hälfte der Killstreaks war ein S in Black Ops 1. Die haben gesucked. Aber die andere Hälfte war geil und SS71, huge.
Ne Ghost war Campstrike, Moab war in MW3. Da ist die, da ist die Moab.
So, was haben wir denn sonst noch? Was ist das? What the fuck?
Weil der hat einen Lego-Kran gebaut. Was ist denn das, geht mit den Leuten wieder ab.
Okay, das hat ein bisschen gedauert, glaube ich. Vor allem, wie der einfach mal einen Lego-Kran im Wohnzimmer stehen hat.
Kann man den nicht sogar kaufen? Kann man das? Ich dachte, das ist irgendwie so ein selbstgebildetes Ding.
Aber übelst nice. Nicht, dass man damit was anfangen könnte, aber cool ist das trotzdem.
Dass der einfach einen Kran im Wohnzimmer stehen hat. Krass. Also Lego-Kran. Das ist nicht, das ist viel zu advanced, ja.
Ist doch nice. Doch nice. Einfach mal einen Kran aus Lego.
Richtig poggers. Man sieht, wie groß das Ding ist. Hier hat er einen Sessel stehen und daneben steht der Kran. Das Ding ist zwei Meter hoch oder so.
Man muss keinen Stuhl hochheben. Also, da hat er bestimmt einen Kran gebaut.
Heftig. Sieben Meter. Moment. What the fuck? What the fuck?
Aber hier hinten muss er ein richtig fettes Gewicht dran haben, dass es nicht umkippt.
Einfach einen sieben Meter Lego-Kran. Voll was im Hals.
Das ist so hoch wie das Haus fast. Aber da hat er eine Weile dran gebastelt.
Das ist nicht von heute auf morgen. Fertig.
Oh. Immerhin. Immerhin. Es kann ein Smartphone hochheben. Aber viel mehr muss ich ja überlegen, wenn das Ding sieben Meter lang ist und vorne noch was zusätzlich hochhebt. Das zieht halt ganz schön.
Das ist Big Brain. Mit dem Handy filmen, wie es hochhört. Jetzt erstmal droppen. Bring mal das Smartphone hoch.
Guck mal, das kann er wirklich jetzt auf den Balkon legen. Er ist gar nicht mehr dran. Und er kann sogar dabei fahren.
Massive. Guck mal, wie geil ist das? Huge.
Also was die Leute hier alles bauen. Das ist heftig.
Was passiert, wenn man ein 29 Dollar Laptop auf Facebook bestellt? Wahrscheinlich Scam würde ich sagen.
Scam-Arst. Scam-Arst. Facebook.
Yes.
Ja.
Das stimmt schon. Ich kann es auch schwer erkennen. Ich finde, der Shop sieht tatsächlich richtig nach so einem Shop aus, der nur aufgesetzt wurde zum Scammen.
Es ist schwierig zu sagen, woran man das fest macht. Vielleicht hier unten ein bisschen. Auch, dass es so nach einem 0815 Standard-Template aussieht.
Dass die Schrift hier oben übelst sackt. Es ist schwierig zu erkennen, aber so das Gesamtbild sieht irgendwie nach Scam-Shop aus.
Ja, das haben sie immer gerne.
Ihr wisst ja auch, nur heute kriegt ihr den kostenlosen Kurs, wie ihr in einer Woche Millionär werdet. Morgen ist das Ganze nicht mehr kostenlos.
Also jetzt anmelden und jetzt der WhatsApp-Gruppe joinen.
Ja, das ist nicht von denen.
Das ist die bessere Variante.
Das riecht schon ganz hart nach...
Die Mail sieht auch so übelst zusammencopy-pasted aus.
Guck mal, please don't worry. Also, please don't worry. Klingt nach legit customer service.
Oh, da kam was an. Das hätte ich gar nicht gedacht.
Das ist ja komplett unrelated. Ich habe jetzt gedacht, die hätten mir nicht so eine Plastikbox geschickt oder so.
Okay.
Weg!
Ja, ganz ehrlich, ich bin noch nie auf die Idee gekommen, über irgendeine Werbung, sei es YouTube, Facebook, Twitter, Ads, was auch immer, was zu kaufen.
Noch nie, ohne Scheiß noch nie. Das Einzige, was mich dazu gebracht hat, ist vielleicht irgendein Review-Video von Leuten, die ich gerne kucke auf YouTube.
Beispielsweise, wenn ich irgendein Video gesehen habe, da wurden irgendwelche Werkzeuggeschichten gezeigt, die mir gefallen haben, dann habe ich was bestellt.
Aber ich bestelle eigentlich nie über Werbe-Ads. Nie.
Auch nicht auf Google, also ich bestelle nie über Ads.
Facebook ist es dem egal.
Wisst ihr eine Sache, die ich nicht verstehe bei dieser Werbe-Geschichte?
Twitch, YouTube, die sind immer dabei, dass ihre Content-Creator, die sollen alle, also vor allem die Aushängeschilder, die sollen alle weißer als weiß sein.
Ich meine da mit weiße Weste, also ich meine jetzt nicht, also ihr wisst, bevor jetzt wieder irgendjemand ankommt.
Also die sollen alle reiner als rein, könnte man sagen, sein.
Also sprich, die sollen keinerlei in keinerlei Skandale verwickelt sein und in keinerlei, die sollen wirklich so Engelsgleich, so irgendwie Vorzeigeläute sein.
So Rollmodels, also die Aushänge Content-Creator.
Also sprich, die Twitch und YouTube, die stellen so hohe Anforderungen quasi an ihre Aushänge Content-Creator.
Aber auf der anderen Seite haben sie die übelste Scam-Shady-Werbung am Start.
Da frage ich mich, was schadet der Reputation einer Plattform mehr?
Ehm, einen Content-Creator, der ab und zu mal das falsche Wort verwendet, weil er gerade irgendwie in Action ist und nicht richtig aufpasst, oder Scamas-Shady-Werbung?
Also ich bevorzuge authentische Content-Creator, die sich auch mal verplappern dürfen, mehr als überall nur korrekte Leute.
Und wenn ich merke, dass der Content-Creator ein Depp ist, dann gucke ich ihn halt nicht.
Raid Shadow Legends, genau.
More Videos like this, okay.
Was haben wir sonst noch?
Wie Subway sich selbst zerstört.
Haben wir das nicht schon mal geguckt?
Ich frage mich, warum hat mir YouTube das heute vorgeschlagen?
Manchmal komme ich mir übelst verfolgt vor, ne?
Wir haben gestern im Stream nach einem Subway geguckt und heute kriege ich Subway-Videos empfohlen.
Das stimmt doch irgendwas nicht.
Valorant Netcode-Analyse.
Overclocking Wunder.
Battlefield 4 Plays.
How to Twitch Chat PogChamp.
How to Twitch Chat Forehead.
Das gucken wir jetzt.
Chat, wir müssen uns heute mal ein bisschen weiterbilden.
Haben wir das nicht schon geguckt?
Die People Emotes haben wir schon geguckt.
Okay, nochmal.
Ist richtig gut gemacht.
Alright, alright.
Quiet down, quiet down.
Okay, who threw that?
Was it you?
You are always causing trouble in this classroom.
I swear if it was you, you are out of here.
Do you hear me?
Anyways, I will let the culprit go this time, as our lesson today has a lot to do with just getting over things.
First of all, I want to welcome you all back.
The first lesson, I highly recommend you look at a classmate's notes because I am not going to do any review of the last class.
And if you're lost, that is on you.
Without further ado, today let's take a look at another staple base Twitch Emote, Forehead.
And it's FFZ and better TTV variants.
First off, let's look at Forehead, Foreheader and Foreheed.
Foreheader.
Plus the base Forehead Emote all have for the most part the same meaning.
It's just important you understand the context in which they're being used.
We have plus 5 heads and 3 heads.
Well how do I say this?
More dumbed down tutorials for lack of kinder words.
You might be under the impression that Forehead is just used as a reaction to a joke.
Which to some extent is true, but I genuinely don't think I've ever seen the Emote as a replacement to LOL or LOLW.
For me, I rarely use Forehead. If something's funny, I usually use LOLK, LOLW, whatever.
Forehead is more of a...
How do I describe this?
If something...
...isn't as funny as it should be.
If something is...
...if something...
...is...
...is obvious...
...and sounds simple...
...if my PC or my game is shaking and I just need to buy a PC for 5000 Euro.
Or something like that.
Oder so, irgendwie sowas, ja, irgendwas in der Richtung
Ist ja mal situationsabhängig. Ich, ich kann schlecht beschreiben
Wann ich welche Emotes verwende, das ist so impulsiv, ja, oder intuitiv.
So, wenn ich was sehe, kommt das passende Emote quasi automatisch aus meiner Hand getippt
What? Was war das?
Haha, das hat keck weh gerade am Start.
Guck ich nicht, ich guck ja keinen Fortnite
Sag mal, was war das gerade? Achso, das ist ein PC zum durchgucken
Genau, genau, genau, irgendwas, was bei weitem nicht so lustig ist, wie es sein sollte.
Dafür verwende ich zum größten Teil vorher
Das ist, wenn ich jetzt sagen würde, nach dem Motto, zum 25 mal den Witz bringen, nach dem Motto
Warum haben Java-Entwickler Brille auf?
Perfect laugh for a forehead spam
These emails are the most smart ass and sarcastic emotes as you can get
Well besides pepe laughs, but we'll get there another time now that we covered the three main variants
There's also an email that was birthed because of those four hours. Genau haben wir das überhaupt aktiviert
Vorhaus wir haben kein vorhaus
Kann ich mich gar nicht mehr dran erinnern
With their favorite streamer thus das ist das ist hier leute
reverse stonks
Allowing this clip in question to happen. How is somebody homeless just get a house just get a house
Thank you
Situational and it's only used when the words just get a house or said or some variation of the words
But truthfully, it's always funny to see a four-house spamming chat because it is truly so rare
The next two emails will cover today are almost polar opposites to each other
Let's check out three head and five head starting out with three head
Three very unique emo as it was originally created to spam whenever someone with a very strong British accent was on screen
But also only after it was created it got turned into an email to spam
Anytime a British person or anything British related is caught on screen. So using this email is very self-explanatory
See someone even remotely British or in some cases they could even be australian because chat can't tell the difference between two accents
Be ready to unleash the power of all mighty boy. All you made is eher australisch
Shout out to all my three head viewers watching this video. I'll be on fifa later. So you boys better hop on
Excellent kommt jetzt. Das hört sich schon so an exquisite, excellent
Moving on to the most exquisite emo on twitch.television. Let's talk about five head. Whether an extremely...
Das Intro ist zu geil
Excellent, someone smart is explaining something, but most people want to do good and I think I'm one of those people
Where did you get that idea or a word with more than four syllables is said be ready to witness the barrage of five head spam
Usually accompanied with a wine glass and the word exquisite excellent exquisite kid. Oh, that's so funny
Excellent, exquisite kid. Oh, that's so funny. Oh, that's so funny
Five head spam usually accompanied with a wine glass and the word exquisite excellent exquisite kid. Oh
Bestes emote, das ist ja mein absolutes Lieblings emote auf ganz twitch
Was muss ich mir eigentlich holen um die emote statt im text zu sehen moment, das ist eine bildungsgucke
Die müssen wir schließen es gibt zwei sachen das da
Das da oder das da
Die zwei sachen die zwei brau also eins der beiden browser emotes musste holen ich empfehle dir das da weil ich finde es hat mehr funktion
Das browser emote oder das mittlerweile können beide die emotes der jeweils anderen
Ja
Auf dem handy bist du gearscht das stimmt es sei denn du hast den android und verwendest ihren alternativen client
Aber ich habe auch nur noch ffz ffz hat jetzt das letzte feature eingebaut was ich vermisst habe von bettter twitch tv nämlich die chat history
von bettter twitch tv nämlich die chat history
Wenn du ffz installiert hast und die emote nicht siehst musst du in die ffz
settings gehen einmal gif emotes anmachen und das
Und das häkchen dran machen dass du bei der twitch tv emotes haben möchtest
Ich bin hier nicht eingeloggt ich kann das im moment wir machen das jetzt also
Chat
So ich habe sie hier installiert ffz
Dann müsst ihr auf
settings ffz control center
Qt chat genau so und dann gibt es hier zur auswarten ich muss mal ein bisschen größer machen wenn das irgendwie
Und dass ich mal ordentlich resiessen irgendwie das fern was auch immer so dann geht auf bettter twitch tv emotes hier bei addons
Kann man kann man ein häkchen rein machen addons und alles an und vor allem animaten gif emotes
Sollte ja ja ein bild sein genau so sollte das aussehen ja
Dazu musst du bei addons bettter twitch tv emotes anmachen
Bettter twitch tv emotes
Bettter twitch tv emotes musste unter addons einschalten
Und mach also man sollte auch die animated emotes anmachen ja also
Was haben wir für animated emotes smart
Also ich kann hier gar nicht schreiben weil ich bin ich eingeloggt also too smart haben wir zum beispiel animiert
Das musste anschalten
und
Im Prinzip eben
Und im prinzip im prinzip was das
Kannst hier oben auch suchen animated emotes
Kannst relativ viel machen das wichtigste ist dass du bettter twitch dass du hier unter addons
Bettter twitch tv emotes einschaltet
Und enables und der addons bettter twitch tv emotes enable und dann einschaltet
Wie bist du auf das gekommen wo du grad bist ja unten auf das rad und dann auf franker face z
control center aber es ist ja eigentlich ja franker faces
control center faces
the franker z
So und dann gehst du auf addons machst bettter twitch tv emotes an und in den settings von bettter twitch tv emotes machst du alles an
global emotes pro emotes channel emotes alle emotes und
Wenn du das hier anmachst dann hast du auch das hier wird dann zu einem emote
Macht mal einer das machst grad sieht aber ich kann sie selbst mal noch mal im vorschaubildschirm
Das wird dann auch zu einem emote einfach alles anmachen und gif emotes enable wenn man gif emotes
Enabled hat dann kann man dann auch solche sachen hier verwenden
Exquisite 5 hat kann man dann verwenden
Wenn ihr noch was sehen wollt fragt mich mit twitch emotes kann ich die mittlerweile aus
Danke es funktioniert feinlich ex exquisite
Ja, 5 hat spam usually accompanied with a wine glass and the word exquisite
This email is used to show that something intelligent is happening or yes
Also ich ich kenne es mit zwei sachen einmal ex exquisite und auch ah yes ist auch sehr beliebt
Wubbels der kommentator acht monatang schon
Exquisite subscription
Scrimmage a five head spam usually accompanied with a wine glass and the word exquisite
This email is used to show that something intelligent is happening indeed
Although a decent portion of five heads use is used sarcastically when a streamer is pretending to say something intelligent. It's solid. They have a they have a
Velocity property
Where they where they where they break if the frequencies pitches are too high for the time space continuums
Just like this email is also pretty self-explanatory, although there are some combinations
You should know about besides the five head with a wine glass. Ah, yes was it next to it. There is also
Ah, yes. Ah, yes
Also, ah, yes
precisely
And of course of course
Would be the best way to witness this emo in its raw form
The next two emails are also interchangeable with each other with one just being a w version of the prior
Let's take a look at four weird and four weird w
Verwendet nicht
This email has a very niche community. You'll notice this email has a lot of use in e-robs
Who is the younger brother to that one league of legends addicts?
I forgot his name though. Anyways, the email has a lot of use in this channel
A little subsection of streamers as well
It's effectively replaced weird champ for a lot of those streamers, which is understandable as four weird is genuinely
Four weird nee, habe ich noch nie verwendet
Using this email is very similar to weird champ
But it's more often focused at the streamer more than anything else
This email is quite popular, but you're not going to see it everywhere as it's only enabled in around 4200 channels
Heading over to l rob's channel is probably your best bet to see this email live and in action
And the last email that will be covered today is for shrug. This is a hybrid. Hab ich noch nie gesehen and forehead on top of it
This email is used when even the all-knowing twitch chat doesn't even have the answer to the question a streamer is asking
Of the cases that the question is asked it usually stems from a streamer either playing a brand new game
Or a random early access game that no one's heard of at all
And well in turn the streamer is met with a barrage of four shrug spammers
Just like the four house email this email is quite situational, but it's still very easy to understand and master
Okay class don't forget to bring your notebooks next lesson if you forgot today next lesson is on the pepe emails
And it's a big one that will span two classes. Das haben wir schon gesehen. So, please bring your notebook. Das haben wir schon gesehen. Please be prepared
Das video hat mir gefallen. Ich will jetzt noch lernen how to poke champ
Hey, you. Yeah, you
Does mindlessly typing me into a chat sound like you er meint uns chat er meint uns
Wir werden angesprochen er redet mit uns
You does mindlessly typing emotes into a chat sound like fun to you
Want to almost completely lose whatever chrome of social life you had
How about turning off your brain and becoming a massive hive mind if you answered yes to any of those questions?
Oh boy. Oh boy. Do I have something to show you twitch chat?
Now you're probably saying twitch. Well, isn't that the website where you get paid millions? Don't don't poke yet
Top chef for 10 hours a day and to that my good man. All I have to say is that's pretty true
That's true. And yeah, that's true little way
Twitch is such a beautiful place full of beautiful people who have such a strong passion for streaming in its raw form
And it doesn't matter how broke you are if you have time to watch twitch
You have you have ten dollars new talent
Popping up every day
Streaming in its raw form and it doesn't matter how broke you are if you have time to watch twitch
You have you have ten dollars new talent popping up every day
Was
You
And just the friendliest folks you'll ever meet
Over what ranked in 10 sekunden
Ach die ist das
Jetzt erinnere ich dich wieder jetzt easy light sagst grad ja die hat ihre community angemerkt dass sie in den letzten 20 minuten keine subs bekommen
Ach die ist das ja jetzt erinnere ich mich wieder
Ach was vor immer wen interessiert es denn eigentlich ist doch scheiß egal oder
Okay
Mastering more than half of a twitch streams comedic value then you've come to the right place
Whether a joke is being told or an awesome clip happens without twitch chat present
Did it even really happen in the first place?
Hi, i'm serma and i'll be your guide to the wonderful world of twitch chat and how you yourself can dump ours into the most useless
Skill of knowing what email to type at the right moment
So let's jump right into it when watching a stream a lot of the chat will be spamming random words
It's well my fellow and so dumps klingt das ist das beste an twitch und das ist warum keine andere streaming platform an twitch reinkommt
That is where chrome extensions come into play such as franker's face z and better tv
To be able to see anything that twitch chat is spamming you have to download both of these extensions from the chrome store
Two clicks and you're one step closer to mastering the art of speaking in twitch emotes
Just please be careful and don't let this skill transfer to real life
Because the second you speak twitch out in the real world your face
Damit kann ich mich identifizieren
Das rehe ist da
Breathing and sleeping on live stream fills where the biggest degens crawl and slam around spewing bullshit out their mouth 24 7
Trying to farm internet points and you don't want that. Do you?
Good, that's what I thought
So now that you have the extensions installed those random words will actually be transformed into brand new emotes
With so many new emails to explore it can get pretty overwhelming and you might end up making a fool of yourself by accidentally
Misspelling an emote luckily for the most part you can just search for the email instead of typing it in so that should help
Eliminate any it's a huge twitch here education
Being made fun of by twitch chat, but then again, it's twitch chat
Squiz it shouldn't feel that bad in the first place
Because if you think you have it bad that you haven't checked out pokey mains chat yet
This email arguably has the most variants of it and is one of the most legendary base twitch emotes pokey v virgin check
All of the variants of pogchamp
At least the main variants because some people have gone off the rails and made some horrendous freak of nature variants of it
Like poggy, I swear I will wake up one night and see this thing in my closet
So some people have gone off the rails and made some horrendous freak of nature variants of it like poggy
I swear I will wake up one night and see this thing in my closet
So let's start out with poggers
Never and I cannot stress this enough
Never use this emote unironically this email was very popular back in 2018
Right when fortnite was at its peak
So with a wave of kids rushing to twitch to throw their primes at ninja twitch received a lot of new traffic
And somewhere in that poggers was swooped up by all the fortnite community forever tainting the emote and diminishing it
We just spam whenever fortnite or tiktok is mentioned basically anything new and trendy that is also kid-friendly is when poggers
Is the ideal emote to spam in chat now we can have just a moment of silence for our fallen friend poggers
All right enough of that let's learn how to use so selten is poggers jetzt auch nicht
Both of these emotes mean virtually the same thing. There's just two to add some spice to the spam. Ich bevorzuge pog like this
He's almost replaced poggers around 2018 and they're spammed when pog like this and pog
Und cool or crazy happens just like pogchamp, but there are some alternative uses that i'll just touch on
There's a streamer telling a story you don't care about and you don't want to cool story bob him
Instead try doing we don't care pog is something crazy happening that you really don't understand
Well in that case a question mark pog spam is exactly what you need
I've also seen this emote used to replace the white people happy spam in some rare cases
When a death white people happy spam is being commenced, but that is very very few and far between
I wouldn't recommend doing it because it really doesn't make too much sense. But if you do do it
Just be prepared for all the white people happier to barrage you and ultimately sacrifice you to their overlord satan
All in all these various reports straightforward and don't really require much explaining
They have their purpose to serve and they serve it well moving on. Let's take a look at okay champ and everyone's favorite emote
Weird champ. So let's start out with okay champ. This emote is used to well
Let the streamer know that everything is okay
Although a lot of this emotes use is used to show appreciation to someone if they do something commendable
Usually paired with a thumbs up emoji
You can also see this emote spam to show support of another person who is on stream, but isn't the streamer
I would use greek.x as an example, but this isn't 2017
So instead an example that can be used is if xqc is live and everyone's favorite piglet
Soil is invited to play some games for the most part. You'll see chat spam soil okay champ thumbs up emoji
But okay champ is generally used in a very positive manner and an okay champ. Ich habe in letzter zeit so gut wie keine xqc mal geguckt
Keine ahnung wer das ist
But for this next emote i'm not too sure what to say about weird champ is quite a controversial
besta
Warum zum teufel ist weird champ controversial
still very far away from the most controversial twitch
Das hat er gut eingeblendet im hintergrund
Tryhard
Das hat er gut eingeblendet wenn er kennt skam
But that'll be touched on in a later lesson and although weird champ is deemed a controversial emote the argument of triggered by pixels low w
Stands pretty strong as you can personally block any emotes you can't see it anymore. So if you do indeed get triggered by pixels
Warum ist weird champ warum ist das controversial?
The main point of this emote was to be a competitor with haha, which at the time was unheard of the 12 btw
Haha spam was peaking and there seemed to be no stop to the barrage of why chat weird champ is besser
But weird champ busted onto the scene and the haha weird champ war began with weird champ ultimately being deemed victorious
Mostly in part to twitch literally banning people for saying 12 by the way in chat because you need to be at least 13
Wobei ich verwende die beiden emotes haha ist für mich so das cringe emote wenn irgendwie was zum fremd schämen passiert
Und weird champ ist wenn irgendwie was
Was was merkwürdiges also nicht nicht was mehr wenn die leute merkwürdige sachen sagen die aber nicht zum cringen reichen
Dann ist weird champ wenn sie richtig cringe ist dann ist weird champ ist ist haha
Oder wenn einer was ultra lustig findet was nicht lustig ist so dann dann ist ist das angesagt und wenn jetzt irgendwie einer sagt keine ahnung
Ich kacke im handstand dann würde ich sagen weird champ anstatt weird champ
Dann würde ich sagen weird champ anstatt haha
Chambles and the shell of what the emote used to be but enough of the history lesson using this you know is pretty straightforward
See something you don't like or don't agree with weird champ streamer playing with another streamer that you don't like weird champ
Donation with an awful text-to-speech message weird champ
You're gonna want to use this emote when anything is as the emote's name suggests weird
And although this emote has a negative connotation attached to it there are some comedic ways to use this emote
Streamer kills animal on stream instead of using the capital d colon spam weird champ animal killer weird champ or apologize now weird champ
Ich würde sagen call peta weird champ story bob with pog you can also swap in weird champ as well
Streamer telling a boring story or playing into a joke until it's no longer funny try using wrap it up weird champ
Just please i beg you use weird champ responsibly as an unchecked weird champ spam can kill a stream by making everything negative
And the last emote i'll touch on in this lesson is pog o it's an emote that has been gaining quite
Ich habe es nur wegen euch aktiviert im chat ich finde das emote richtig dumm
A bit of popularity over the last few months
It seems as if it's a competitor to weird champ to some extent
But it's still too early to say if a war will break out between the two emotes and the emote does seem quite niche only being used in
3 000 channels compared to weird champs 32 000
But only time will tell if pogo will reign supreme against a powerhouse that is weird champ
And for the rest of the variants of pogchamp
There isn't much to touch on because either they mean the same thing as their counterparts or they're just too obscure and niche and used by emote
elitists to feel more unique emote elitists alles klar
Well, it seems that's all the time I have for today. I hope you learned something from this
I'll be back soon for another lesson on a new emote. Yep, erde ich nicht. Yep, ich bin der einzige der jeppt hier
And i'll see you guys later
Die videos sind übelst gut gemacht. Warum hat er nur 1360 subs
Das war das war mega gut das video vor allem das intro
So, was gucken wir als nächstes?
How to pogchamp, ne das hatten wir grad schon
Only in battlefield
Okay, battlefield haben wir overclocking
Valorant netcode
Analyse wie subway sich selbst zerstört
Programmieren noobfehler
Garagentor
Zukunft von diablo
Was wollen wir jetzt gucken?
Subway? Subway? Ich bin mir nicht sicher
W reader
Jetzt hast du ich schon mal geguckt das subway video
Kannst du keq adden
Keq
Das? Ja das kann ich
Hatte ich sogar
Hatte ich sogar mal vor
das
das wollte ich sogar schon Mal adden
Aber habes da nicht gemacht oder habe ichrob ichursday
aber habs da nicht gemacht oder habe ich doch gemacht
Aber hab's dann nicht gemacht, oder hab ich doch gemacht?
Nee, es ist schon KQ.
Es ist schon KQ.
Moment, gleich ist es da.
Oh.
Äh, FFZ ist kaputt, gerade.
Warum ist FFZ gerade kaputt?
Ah, jetzt. Jetzt geht's.
So, ich hab's geadded.
POG. POG-U.
Wenn ihr refresht, müsste POG-U funktionieren.
Es kann aber auch sein, dass es kurz dauert.
Okay, Subway.
15 cm oder 30?
20.
Wie E-Lott kriegst du Brot?
Hat er nicht immer irgendwas von 20 cm erzählt?
Welche Beilage? Welche Soße?
Salz, Pfeffer?
Jeder kennt die toughen Fragen vom letzten Subway.
Extra Fleisch, extra Fleisch, extra Käse.
Das Ganze sogar von einem Sandwich-Artist.
Die belegen nämlich keine Brote.
Nein. Die erfüllen Wünsche.
Das Wichtigste ist für einen Sandwich-Artist, dass man...
Sandwich-Artist?
Die haben alle immer so überzogene Dinger.
... dass man freundlich ist, dass man auch gut gelaunt in den Job kommt.
Und natürlich auch, dass man schnell arbeitet.
Ja, gut. Soweit die Werbung.
Subway hat heute mehr als 42.000 Restaurants in über 100 Ländern
und gehört damit zu den größten Fast-Food-Ketten der Welt.
Sandwich-Artist ist, wo wir jetzt bei Emotion sind,
ist ein typisches Wort, wo man eindeutig mal sagen kann,
das Wort Sandwich-Artist ist weird champ.
Subway gibt es auf Mauritius, in Alaska, Sibirien und sogar in Afghanistan.
Zweimal.
In den 90ern ist Subway so richtig explodiert.
In den USA verdreifachte sich die Anzahl der Restaurants.
Auch in europäische und asiatische Märkte wurde aggressiv expandiert.
Knapp 30 Jahre später gehen die Umsätze plötzlich zurück.
In den USA müssen Tausende Restaurants schließen.
Der Konzern zerstört sich selbst.
Und man fragt sich...
Warum?
Das erste Subway wurde 1965 in Connecticut eröffnet.
Das Konzept, gesundes Fast-Food, the American Dream.
Das aggressive Wachstum der 90er war nur durch sogenannte...
Enrico, du musst in die Settings einstellen,
dass deine Twitch-Emotes animiert werden.
Du gehst hier hin, Settings, FFZ Control Center,
bei der Twitch-TV-Emotes und schreibst hier
Give Emotes Enabled.
Enabled Animated Give Emotes. Nicht Static Animated.
Und dann hast du hier Annele Clap zum Beispiel.
Das Franchising möglich.
Im Prinzip kann jeder ein Subway-Restaurant aufmachen.
Für eine Gebühr gibt Subway seinen Namen und das Konzept her.
Das Ladendesign, die Art der Zubereitung, die Preise.
Alles wird von Subway vorgegeben.
12,5% des monatlichen Umsatzes gehen direkt an Subway.
Dazu kommen dann noch 10.000 Euro Einstiegsgebühr.
Klingt vielleicht erst mal nach nicht so viel,
ist aber ganz schön viel Geld.
Der Umsatz umfasst nämlich alles, was das Restaurant einnimmt.
Nicht zu verwechseln mit dem Profit.
Der Franchisenehmer muss sich zusätzlich noch um die Einrichtung,
die Miete, die Gehälter der Angestellten
und alle weiteren Kosten kümmern.
Man muss mit knapp 200.000 Euro rechnen,
bevor man überhaupt das erste Sandwich verkaufen kann.
Und das ist sogar schon ziemlich günstig.
Also, wenn du nicht eh schon ordentlich Kohle hast,
wirst du das ja nicht auf die Reihe kriegen.
Muss man mit knapp 1 Million Euro rechnen.
Ähnliche Kosten erwarten einen auch bei Burger King.
Bei Starbucks werden Lizenzen gar nicht an Privatpersonen vergeben.
Das System kann natürlich supergut funktionieren.
Der Franchisenehmer profitiert von der Mark und dem Image
und kümmert sich dafür um das Tagesgeschäft.
Es wird allerdings ziemlich unschön,
wenn der Franchisengeber eine Fehlentscheidung nach der anderen trifft
und die Franchisenehmer darunter leiden.
Gab es da nicht die Geschichte,
dass Subway Sandwiches zumachen mussten,
weil sie in der Nebenstraße von einem anderen Subway Sandwich waren?
Ich kann mich noch dunkel dran erinnern.
Da gab es letztens was, wo sich alle übelst darüber aufgeregt haben.
Vanilleeis, 21.09. in Twitch Prime. Dankeschön.
Excellent. Huge IQ-Subscription. Dankeschön.
Satte 30 Zentimeter für 5 Dollar.
Jedes US-Restaurant musste mitziehen.
Das gleiche Angebot gab es auch in Deutschland für 5 Euro.
So sieht ein Sandwich aus, la la la.
Ein Sandwich für 5 Euro aus, la la la.
Das ist schon ein bisschen brainert, die Wärmung.
Weird Jam, Weird Jam.
Terongs, neun Monate. Dankeschön für den Sub.
Neun Monate ist ja schon fast...
So konnte Subway seinen Umsatz 2009 um 3,8 Milliarden Dollar steigern.
Ein Riesenerfolg.
Aber ein finanzielles Desaster für viele Franchisenehmer.
Sie waren zu der Zeit mit der wachsenden Konkurrenz beschäftigt.
McDonalds, Wendy's, Burger King und viele andere brachten ab.
Moment. Gibt es das in Deutschland? Nee, oder?
Allesamt neue, gesündere Alternativen auf dem Markt.
Subway war plötzlich nicht mehr...
Gesund in Kokona.
Max, gehst du regelmäßig zu Fastfood lehnen?
Oder eher nicht? Nö, eigentlich gar nicht mehr.
...wurden durch den relativ unprofitablen 5 Dollar Footlong
dann nur noch höher.
Aber Subway meinte so...
Das reicht uns nicht!
2016 wurde der 5 Dollar Deal endlich abgeschafft.
Für eine kurze Zeit wollte Subway das Angebot wieder einführen.
Der Plan wurde aber von einer Revolte der Franchisenehmer verhindert.
Ach ja, und wenn man Subway nicht direkt bezahlt,
droht direkt die Klage.
Auch wenn man kurz vorm Bankrott steht, ist das also keine Option.
Die Verhandlung wird dann laut 700 Seiten dickem Vertrag
vor einem Schiedsgericht in New York stattfinden.
Viel Spaß, wenn du dafür ohne Geld in der Tasche auf Sibirien anreisen musst.
Bei anderen Franchise-Unternehmen gibt es solche Extremfälle wesentlich seltener.
McDonalds und Burger King betreuen ihre Franchisenehmer viel enger.
McDonalds sucht beispielsweise die Standorte der Restaurants aus
und richtet sie ein.
Erst dann werden sie an die Betreiber verpachtet.
Sie sind also weniger auf sich allein gestellt.
Subway hat noch ein weiteres Problem.
Die Restaurants müssen keinen Mindestabstand...
Das stimmt, aber sehr viele Subways sind einfach dicht,
die es bei uns um die Ecke früher gegeben hat.
Also, wie gesagt, dort, wo ich immer hin bin mittags,
Subway holen gibt es ja schon Jahre nicht mehr.
...voneinander haben.
So graben sich viele gegenseitig die Kunden ab.
In Manhattan kann das Ganze dann schnell so aussehen.
Franchisenehmer, die sowieso schon strugglen,
werden dadurch nur noch weiter unter Druck gesetzt.
Aber auch gut laufende profitable Restaurants sind nicht sicher.
Die einzelnen Restaurants werden von regionalen Development Agents koordiniert.
Eigentlich müssten sie dafür sorgen,
dass nicht zu viele Subways nebeneinander eröffnet werden.
Die meisten dieser Development Agents sind aber selber auch Franchisenehmer.
Sie konkurrieren also...
Klingt ein bisschen nach voreingenommen.
Mit den Läden.
Niko, ich find Subway auch nicht schlecht, ich ess Subway an sich ganz gern.
...die sie eigentlich beaufsichtigen sollen.
Das ist aber natürlich kein Interessenskontroler.
Auch wenn schon lang kann's vergessen werden.
Subway ist es nur wahnsinnig wichtig,
dass die Development Agents jeden Aspekt des Unternehmens genau verstehen.
Also auch wie es ist, einen zu besitzen.
Dass gut laufenden Restaurants wegen fadenscheiniger Argumente
immer wieder die Lizenzen entzogen werden,
hängt ganz sicher nicht damit zusammen.
Dass die Agents wenig später im selben Gebiet
als neue Subway-Besitzer auftauchen, ist vermutlich auch nur Zufall.
Subway-Besitzer haben versucht,
gegen die Machenschaften der Development Agents zu klagen.
Nur wenige hatten Erfolg, auch weil Subway ihnen keine Rückendeckung gibt.
2016 haben mehr Subway-Restaurants dichtgemacht als neue aufgemacht.
Das opportunistische Management und die hohen Gebühren
haben zahlreiche Restaurantbesitzer in den Ruinen getrieben.
Und dazu kommen Skandale.
Jared Vogel war 15 Jahre lang Werbesprecher für Subway.
Er hat behauptet, mit Subway-Produkten
über 100 kg abgenommen zu haben.
Okay, also wer sowas glaubt,
dass rein vom Subway-Sandwich essen,
man jetzt 100 kg abnimmt,
es kommt drauf an, was man sonst noch so macht.
Ich mein, wenn ich Subway-Sandwich esse
und danach zusätzlich meinen ganzen anderen Kram Schwachsinn,
wenn ich nur ein Subway-Sandwich am Tag esse
und dazu noch Sport mache und sonst wie, klar,
aber dann muss es auch kein Subway-Sandwich sein.
Das könnte ich auch mit irgendwie x-beliebig anderen Sachen machen.
Oh, Penobäher-Alarm.
... entpuppte sich die Werbeikone als Pedophiler.
Skandale kommen natürlich meistens unerwartet.
Sie sind aber ein zusätzliches Risiko für Franchisenehmer.
Wenn Subways Image geschädigt wird,
werden die Umsätze schließlich noch weiter nach unten getrieben.
Einige Subway-Besitzer sehen sich dadurch gezwungen,
auf minderwertige Produkte zurückzugreifen.
Die Qualität leidet also auch unter dem enormen Kostendruck.
Immer wieder berichten ausgestiegene Sandwich-Artists
von Hähnchenfleisch, das mehrere Tage in der Auslage bleibt.
Wenn es nicht stinkt, gerne auch mal 10.
Das Ganze ist...
Das würde es ganz ehrlich erklären,
dass ich, das war ja auch die letzten Male,
wo ich einen Subway besucht habe.
Seitdem gehe ich nicht mehr hin.
Unser Subway hat ja dicht gemacht
und seitdem sind wir ab und zu ja mal,
also in Frankfurt dann, da wo noch nicht nur Homeoffice war,
also schon ein bisschen her, zum Subway gefahren sind.
Da musstest du schon ein Viertelstunde,
20 Minuten mit der U-Bahn hin und dann futtern.
Und da war ich 3-mal und hatte jedes Mal übelst dünn Schiss danach.
Und seitdem gehe ich dann immer hin.
Bis jetzt nur eine amerikanische...
Und bin nie wieder zu Subway gegangen danach.
Außerdem gibt es immer Franchisenehmer,
die sich von den Erfolgsversprechen anlocken lassen.
Der tatsächliche Schaden für Subway
könnte also überschaubar bleiben.
Die Kette wird von Tausenden von Menschen getragen.
Sie alle haben viel Zeit und viel Geld
in ihren Traum der Selbstständigkeit investiert.
Sie haben das radikale Wachstum der 90er
überhaupt erst ermöglicht.
Schade, dass Subway genau diese Menschen
heute so rücksichtslos ausnutzt.
Und sich so letztlich das eigene Fundament raubt.
Cheers!
Hahaha
Arte
Das haben wir im Valorant Netcode-Analyse.
Oh, der macht das immer richtig big brain.
Was haben wir sonst noch so?
Many people...
Ich will sehen, wie der Typ sein Hoftor automatisiert.
Das interessiert mich irgendwie.
Today on the hookup,
I'm gonna walk you through every step
of a simple DIY home automation project.
As we convert a standard garage door
into a smart one for less than $25,
I'm gonna do my best to explain
all the terminology I use
with this pop-up video style bubble.
Making this the perfect video
for any beginner DIY automator.
In my house tour, I mentioned that my smart garage door
was my first DIY automation project.
And that for the money,
it's probably one of my most famous smart computers.
When I was first starting out,
every massive video and tutorial that I watched
was full of a bunch of terminology
that I didn't really understand.
And as a result, I fumbled around with a lot of failed protocols
before finally figuring out what I was doing.
This is the video that I wish existed
when I was first starting out.
This video is sponsored by PCBWay,
a printed circuit board manufacturer.
This video is sponsored by PCBWay, a printed circuit board manufacturer.
of all types, assembly and PCB design services.
So whether you're a professional electrical engineer
or a tinkerer,
PCBWay can help you make your projects a reality.
Now PCBWayheads celebrating their
6th anniversary with some great sales.
And as always, new customers are eligible
for $5 off their first order,
which makes your first order
of 10 circuit boards basically free.
Check out the links down in the description.
Check again when I'm making a showcase.
10 circuit boards basically free check out the links down in the description
To do this project. I'm going to use four different things
I'm going to explain more about what they are and why we need now das meine ich ja also du musst du musst wirklich auch sagen
Ich weiß nicht wie das heißt du musst du musst halt auch
Kupfer also muss auch verbindung ziehen von einem pin dahin vom nächsten pin dahin
Und genau wie es auf dem board laufen soll ich habe mal irgendwann tutorial geguckt aber ich weiß nicht wie die einzelnen schritte davon heißen
und
Later, aber hier sind sie. Erstens ist es shelly 1 beste beste
Zweitens ist es eine reed switch und ein magnet
Dr. Einen 12 volt AC adapter und dann nur ein bisschen wire
Ich möchte definitiv klar machen, dass es zutreffend gebildete smart garage door solutionen von kompanien wie moos und
Also für mich wäre eine garage door automatisierung komplett sinnlos
Wie gesagt ich fahre mit dem auto nicht rein und es wird eh zum größten teil einfach als ablage man könnte es fast als
so an müllhalde bezeichnet
verwendet abstellkammer
Kein, wann baut er denn ich will eigentlich nur sehen wie es am ende aussieht
Sehen, wie es am ende ausschaut
Zeig, oh, big brain
Kokona steckdose
freedom freedom plop power plug
Plug in both your garage door opener and your 12 volt adapter
If all goes well you should now be able to see the state of your garage door as indicated by the blue
coloration of the power button in your shelly app and you should be able to trigger the garage door to open and close using the
Power button which again causes that relay to fire for one second and then turn back off
Also ich hätte so was schon am start würde ich meine garage verwenden um rein rauszufahren
It does this by connecting to a computer server called the shelly cloud normally
Ja, okay, ich wollte eigentlich nur in aktion sind aber was gucken wir uns jetzt an was von uns angucken valorant netcode, ne?
Kann ich die garage auch über meine telekom dosen mit strumpf ja aber nur mit adapter
Voll stylishes intro
It is quite a challenge to get an online multiplayer game to feel responsive smooth and fair
Many different systems which are referred to by the blanket term netcode must work together to achieve these goals in today's video
We will take a look at valorant from riot games and how your experience is affected by its netcode
But since the netcode consists out of many complex systems you must have a basic understanding of what terms like update rates
Oh exquisite video that fits big brain topics risk to either be overwhelmed by the information provided in today's video or even worse
You might end up drawing the wrong conclusions to make it easy for you
I've created a netcode one of one video where I explain all you need to know about the networking in online multiplayer games
You can find a link to that video in the description
Packet loss latency variation as well as a high ping are three factors that can destroy your online experience
Because of that it's important that the game tells you when your connection to the server has an issue
Only then you know why your online experience is bad and what you can do to troubleshoot spray and pray unlike many other developers riot games
Understands how important it is to give players access to that information and so valorant not only provides warning icons
Die skin prices sind eine Frechheit ja
Ich glaube wie war das für 100 für 100 dollar
oder waren es 200 dollar dieses dragon dings bla skin pack wie auch immer das heißt
Ping issues it also provides additional overlays which let you monitor the service tick rate your clients frame rate as well as frame time
And among many other things you can monitor packet loss as well as the network round trip time also known as latency or ping
Now let's take a closer look at that network round trip time value the game shows me a net
Überskinnen man darf sich über alles beschweren warum soll man sich nicht über skin preise beschweren dürfen
wirklich darf man sich über skin preise beschweren
120 euro ist ja schon echt teuer man klar letztendlich muss es nicht kaufen
Aber man kann sich trotzdem drüber beschweren dass es zu teuer ist weil
Versetzt sich mal in die situation rein irgendjemand würde gerne den skin kaufen das ist ihm zu teuer also
darf er sich auch drüber beschweren warum nicht
brauchen tust du nicht
Aber beschweren kannst du dich trotzdem drüber zumal in der heutigen zeit kannst du dich über alles beschweren warum sollst du dich nicht über skin preise beschweren dürfen
But when I ping that IP then I get a round trip time which is nearly 10 milliseconds lower than what the game shows me
The reason behind this in perso faxer sind die sachen auch teilweise ultra teuer wenn du überlegst dass da irgendwie den schild skin
Teilweise 150 points kostet 150 points sind was 20 euro oder so das ist das ist teilweise auch komplett übertrieben
Trotzdem habe ich mir welche gekauft
Das ist ein gutes thema die schreibt die skins sind trotzdem billiger als wenn man die mit lootboxen freischalten würde hier sieht man wenigstens wie behinderteuer das ist
das ist eindeutig ein fall von
Den den preis in den köpfen der leute also die sachen in den köpfen der leute
künstlich wertvoller machen als sie eigentlich sind das ist was was gerne mobile games machen
also du kriegst dann in mobile games haben wir zum beispiel sachen drinne wie
Du kannst dir einen juwel für ein euro kaufen oder fünf juwelen für fünf euro
Und dann gibt es den juwel pack einen monat gratis testen mit fünf juwelen umsonst drinne und dann denkst du
Klar natürlich ich macht es monat gratis
Und dann das gibt künstlich einer sache den wert den es nicht hat
Das ist so typische mobile taktik mobile game taktik
Wisst ihr was ich meine also mal angenommen ich mache eine preisliste als mobile oder als game anbieter und schreibe hin
Ein microtransaction point kostet einen euro fünf microtransaction points kosten keine ahnung vier euro oder so
So und dann dann hat dann habe ich dem irgendwie einen preis zugeordnet also
Fünf points vier euro ein point ein euro was im kopf hängen bleibt ist so ungefähr ein euro pro
pro point so und jetzt verkaufe ich den monats abo was allerdings den ersten monat kostenlos ist wo man sogar fünf points
umsonst kriegt oder fünf points nur für ein euro oder irgendwie was in der richtung und schon sagen die leute
Cool hier kriege ich ja quasi was was sonst vier euro kostet kriege ich für ein euro das lohnt sich ja viel mehr dabei ist es
ein komplett fiktiver preis ohne
irgendwie
Eine begründung also anhaltspunkt warum das jetzt auf einmal so viel wert sein soll
Das ist so eine taktik das machen die mal mobile games ultra gerne und zwischen you and the data
Seid ihr auch bei allen möglichen webshops
Routing
Ja der ist der ist bestellt bestimmt ins disco zertifikat er sagt routing
Your data might take a direct route which keeps the network delay and the risk of packet loss low
But you can also end up in a situation where your data takes quite a detour
Which can have a very negative impact on your connection to the server
So amazon's global accelerator service aims to decrease the latency and increase the stability of the connection
By having the traffic of an application enter their own network through one of the nearer. Das ist eigentlich gar nicht doof
It is similar to how services like haste or wt fast. Ja das ist eigentlich gar nicht doof
routing your data through their own network
One of the reasons why developers choose to use a service like und du musst den kram natürlich auch nicht selbst betreiben das ist
Echt nicht schlecht dass es so was mittlerweile gibt für für halbwegs erschwinglich
Get the problem of players with a low and stable ping to the server
Receiving damage behind cover when they get shot by a player who has a bad connection to the server a service like the
AWS global accelerator helps to reduce the round trip time of your player base
But it does not help when players suffer from buffer bloat or congestion inside their whole network
Which can lead to massive ping spikes of several hundred milliseconds
It also doesn't help much when a player connects to a server outside his own region
Ja for these instances you need other lag mitigation strategies that prevent players who have a connection issue
From degrading the online experience of players who have a good and stable connection to the server
So even though I had to slightly lead my shot which suggests that Valorant does use a threshold for how much lag it
Compensates the player with the low ping still received a shot quite far behind cover
On a positive note there are no hits from the grave
Which means that the server will cancel a hit from a player if the player was killed before
Nicht wie in Battlefield. Es ist nicht wie in Battlefield wo die leute mit ewig ping
Die dich quasi um fünf ecken killen wenn sie selbst schon in die luft geflogen sind
Ja oder sich gegen oder dich gegenseitig. In Battlefield war es teilweise gang und gäbe dass du dich gegenseitig gekillt hast
As the in-game overlay shows the game servers run at a tickrate of 128 hertz which means that they do 128
simulation steps per second as I explained in the netcode one video a high tickrate not only reduces delays
It also makes the game more resilient. Ich mein, wie war das 10er tick server in Warzone?
It's less of an issue then and clients have to do less guesswork between packets than in other games which run at a lower tick rate
If you suspect the game server to have a performance issue
Then you should enable this overlay and keep an eye on the simulation rate if it stays at 128
Then all should be fine. If you see it drop constantly or not even reach
128 which I've not seen during my testing
Then this suggests that the server has a performance issue which can have a negative impact on your online experience
Außer genau außer man hat außer man spielt über Stadia
Dann ist es dann hat man negative latency
Warzone für eine tickrate. Ich glaube warzone hatte hatte eine 10er tickrate
20er 20er 20er oder 12er
Aber
Auf jeden fall wenig
Look at the update rates or how frequently data is sent and received
Sadly, there is no in-game overlay which shows us the update. Ist vielen sich nicht normal nicht
Das hängt komplett von der Implementierung und vom Game ab wie du es machst
But these are easy to measure with wire shark so when you play Valorant with more than
144 fps on a
128 tick server then as long as you are alive your clients and 73 seconds to the server
When you die then the cent rate of your client drops to about five updates per second
But that's not an issue because you are dead then
The cent rate of the server on the other hand is around
115 packets per second and it doesn't drop when you die
However, I decided to calculate the average only for the time I was alive
So that these average values are for the same portion of the recorded data. What I find interesting
Is that the cent rate of the client seems to be at a somewhat stable 73 packets per second
Usually you see game clients use a cent rate that at least matches the tick rate of the server
So it might be possible to further decrease the network delay and Valorant by increasing the cent rate of the client to
128 packets per second
When it comes to the variable cent rate of the server then the developers most likely have to server only send necessary updates to the client
Aber ich kann ja da eh ne, ich kann ja da als Spieler nix ändern
Good thing as that reduces the stress on the players internet connection where packets per second can turn into a limiting factor before bandwidth
Besides the performance overlays Valorant has another interesting setting in its options menu called network buffering
Which you can set to minimum moderate or maximum when you have network buffering
Then you might think of how the interpolation ratio in counter-strike works
So I thought that this setting would change how many incoming packets get buffered which increases the network delay
But can help with stuttering player animations, especially when you suffer from packet loss
However, it seems like the network buffering setting in Valorant doesn't work that way
Take a look at what happens when the player in front of me changes his network buffering setting
When he changes the setting it causes that his player model stutters on my client
This setting does not affect the animation smoothness of how he sees other players
But how smooth his player model moves for everyone else
Okay, das heißt die meisten Leute stellen das jetzt alle auf maximum oder wie
This feature actually does when you choose the moderate or maximum network buffering setting then these decrease
How frequently your client sends data to the server?
Fewer updates sent means that your player model stutters for other players and that you have more network delay
The only reason why you would want to choose any other value than minimum here is when the send rate of the game
Causes issues for internet connection, but I do not like that players are even given that option
The game should on its own be able to determine when the internet connection of a player cannot handle the default update rates and then adjust them
Automatically we can look at battlefield as a great example here
Which uses such a system since battlefield 4 and it works really well
That said I do not like that the animation of a player starts to stutter for everyone else when the send rate of this player is reduced
Yeah, though preventing that would probably increase the delay for everyone as the game then might have to buffer more packets and interpolate between them
Now let's take a look at the delays the two players experience when they play on the same server and at the same network latency of
24 milliseconds
Long story short the delays for damage, gunfire and player movement were not only good
They are also nearly identical, which is quite rare
There is also only a very small difference between the shortest average and longest delays
Which is one of the positive effects a high tick rate of 128 Hertz has on the delays
That said compared to other games there is still room for improvement here
So I'm curious how the network delays in Valorant will hopefully improve as the developers continue to update the game
Warum ist Apex Legends so schlecht?
Ich hätte eigentlich gedacht das Apex, also gerade weil es so Titanfall background ist ziemlich ziemlich gut für uns
Warzone ist leider nicht drin
Overwatch ist allgemein ziemlich gut was Netzwerksachen angeht, also über eine Sache kann man sich bei
Overwatch nicht beschweren, netzwerktechnisch ist das Spiel wunderbar
Now, even though the next two features are only indirectly related to the netcode and the online performance of the game
I still want to highlight that the developers decided to have the game determine the highest supported refresh rate of your monitor
And then only allow the player to choose which one of the two features they want to use
Is das so?
Oh
Alter was ist mit den Gegnern wieder los?
The fuck? Die Schneibers
Richtig hängen geblieben, ey
Ich mach den absichtlich nicht lauter, weil der sagt eh immer das gleiche und ich schwätze immer drüber
Console Graphics
Was ist das? PS3?
Aber eigentlich die Auflösung ist hoch für PS3
Das ist glaube ich, das ist glaube ich doch PC, nur mit schlechter Capture
What the fuck?
Was Playstation? Okay
Ja so Dinger hast du viele, sowas hattest du aber an vielen Stellen im Battlefield
So was hattest du aber an vielen Stellen im Battlefield, dass du Wände hattest wo du nicht durchschießen konntest
Oh
Na trifft er ihn jetzt noch?
Hä?
Weird Champ
Der ist nicht mal gestorben
What
What the hell
Ja, aber das sind so Sachen, die sind geil, dass sie in Battlefield unscripted passieren
Der hat halt den Chat auf den Kopf gekriegt
Oh
Bäm
Wow
Double Hit mit einer und das sieht das habe ich noch nie gesehen
What the
Battlefield Physics
What
Game
Hahaha
She baited
Das geht?
Das geht
Geil
Das muss ich gleich nachher ausprobieren